thank you
[Music]
we want to start this this one off right
here with a little photo
so uh
it's been in my face all right anybody
anybody anybody she looks like she's
political okay what else does she look
like she looks slippage Caucasian nice
nice great detailing is this not the
same person no it's the same person
everybody know who this is what do you
want me to do is she an actress is she
an actor don't get angry what do you
want me to do dude look at his eyebrows
he's pissed is she political just
political what's that flag button on her
is that a flag it might be a flag if you
if it was a flag it would be the Finnish
flag oh she's the Finnish prime minister
this is the Finish Line shout out to the
Finnish prime minister she was uh I I
heard about this situation so uh she is
a finland's party loving prime minister
her name is uh Santa Marin party loving
what's party she's found herself in some
hot water again well she loves again
yeah again this time after a topless
photo leaked of two young women two
women kissing at her taxpayer-funded
summer residents come on that's good she
one of the topless women nah no no she's
not the fresh photos are the latest
controversy for the 36 year old Finnish
leader coming out less than a week after
she's younger than us in a prime
minister she was dancing right yeah
after she got some criticism with the
video of her partying with celebrities
and influencers the picture which has
been circulated by Finnish media shows
two women kissing while they lift their
tops to Bear their breasts I mean she's
having a great time right she's having a
great time well what's the problem like
ish is it because they're using taxpayer
money to answer the question Joe what
what is the problem I don't know I don't
think there is a problem you know the
British guy Boris what's his name yeah
Johnson's gone
that was different though he was
partying a lot the downfall but that's
all the human being like hey by the way
covet lockdowns he was doing I mean he
got extra stuff on it but it was
attached to him yeah partying too but he
doesn't have videos of two chicks making
out lifting their boobs I guess that's
true even if even if Obama was at a
party and that happened they would still
it would still be the news first of all
I always think like it's plus they're in
Europe right but the politicians are the
kings and queens and for every era kings
and queens have been doing their damn
thing since the beginning of time
they're all [ __ ] each other since the
beginning of time yep wait who's on her
[ __ ] governor
knew something he got in trouble parting
too but he got another term but their
parties looked boring that's it yeah it
was a lame party this girl's pretty cute
hey I was in Finland she is cute
oh
I heard that Scandinavians have the
hottest people on Earth but they're not
scamming I do think Scandinavians are
[ __ ] fine I thought they were
scandinated with their I think they're
baltics Balkans finished Finnish people
aren't Scandinavian they stop nowhere
but they're not they're Balkans so
really Scandinavian wait Finnish people
yeah Finland Sweden
but they're actually not they're
actually something else maybe it's that
it's no it's Norway it's Denmark and
it's Sweden yeah those are the
Scandinavians fins anyways this is the
photo
um so she had a sign it was covering or
like the two times it says Finland oh
it's not even that bad I thought it was
amazing it's not but it's it's the prime
minister's residence they party dude I
recently was in Helsinki like a month
ago what is that in Finland that's the
capital of Finland for Comic Con no I
was there we wrote me and my girlfriend
Alice wrote a movie that takes place in
Finland so we were scouting the movie
there and we were hanging out with a
bunch of Finnish actors and production
people uh it's they're they're pretty
they're pretty cool people they like to
party they like to have fun right it's a
cold place first of all it's a cold
place even in the summer well the summer
the sun was out till damn someone's out
I took a picture at midnight the sun was
still sitting oh wow but it only happens
for a small amount of time the rest of
the year there's other times where
there's no light at all that's why they
so white huh yeah they're like oh gee
white
OG white yeah so she's cute she's a cute
leader of of a major country but is this
is this like cool thing with the top
let's see about the party is that more
of a problem to us or to their country
to their country it's it's trending and
it's uh some people it's embarrassing
some people are showing support and
being like yeah she's just a regular
chick like that's you know they're like
they're also posting images of
themselves in similar situations like
parodies in order to kind of show
solidarity with the Prime Minister on
the weekend they like to party yeah but
then of course it's also very
conservative people
big drinking culture I don't see nothing
wrong this is cold they drink a lot I
don't see nothing wrong because to me
there's no real hypocrisy it just seems
like oh [ __ ] taxpayer dollars right the
hypocrisy would be like like Newsome's
kids going to an elementary school and
to keep them secure they have full-on uh
like black SUVs parked outside of the
school engines turned on for 12 hours a
day right but then you're fighting for
electric cars when there is like irony
like that I'm like [ __ ] like how
can you be say hey everybody get
electric cars but my kids are being
guarded by gas vehicles turned on 24 7.
you know that's the stuff that I he
could have got Teslas yeah I feel like
what Gavin Newsom did was more uh
hypocritical than that 100 yeah because
we were allowed to go and have dinners
and he got caught in a [ __ ] Winery no
social distancing no with like 15 people
and he's the [ __ ] that told us to put
on a mask and take it off and chew and
put it back on when we're at a
restaurant did everybody forget that I
feel like that's a very classy you know
photo it's not that bad I forgive her
for everything she does yeah yeah let's
let's not forget if this was our
governor and or leader dude come on
where's the party at she got she got
both of the party yeah
I'm cool that's where Hillary [ __ ] up
if she looked like that she would have
[ __ ] beat Trump anything you look
like that Monica Lewinsky wouldn't
happen that's true okay so she responds
quote I think the picture is not
appropriate I apologize for it such a
picture should not have been taken
um they're just mad that it wasn't her
that's what the real taxpayers are mad
about they're like I paid for your
ticket these not theirs they came to the
party it's not her fault Finland is a
heavy drinking Society yeah because they
live in the cold so when you get
together and you're been drinking speed
you know just drunk all the time then
it's all fruits what are we talking
about we going we're going in and those
those two women picture are believed to
be well known Finnish uh influencers so
it's like I thought they were the
senator there's the influence
um she said that she and her friends
quote had a sauna swam and spent time
together at the post this is another
thing saunas they love it over there huh
this is the deal there are more saunas
in Helsinki the capital of Finland than
there are cars
this is because they told me hey that's
why first of all I sounded like damn
every day every day in my in my Airbnb
we had a sauna wow and then we went to
this really dope sauna Place anybody out
there feeling called Lolly Lolly Lolly
or something like that I want a sauna
we're in this dope sauna is it co-ed
co-ed and then you jump into the Baltic
Sea oh that's so tight that sounds like
fun
there's such a Sonic culture that these
people around each other friggin half
naked all the time not a big deal so
it's no big deal it's cold they need a
sauna they need alcohol
it's healthy for you Sonic with people
is like regular that's like it's not
even it's not even sexual it's just it's
like this and she added that kind of a
picture should not have been taken but
otherwise nothing extraordinary they
were probably
they're influencer chicks like if you're
gonna party with influencers that can be
synonymous with like whatever like
musicians actors rock stars that's a
modern day you know cool wild out kids
right so if you throw a party with
freaking rappers and rock stars you're
gonna you know what I'm saying they're
gonna wow you through a party and
invited all the crazy rappers there yep
guess what's gonna happen someone's
Dick's coming out crazy shit's gonna
happen and people drinking Sonic and
you're drinking and Sonic together
you're drinking in sun and the other
thing is people drinking sauna I did
they gave me a beer they gave me a cider
I'm sitting in a hot ass [ __ ] drinking
the [ __ ] cider and Cocktails have gin
and tonic in the [ __ ] sauna that
sounds like fun if you're getting hand
jobs from the Prime Minister
everything's [ __ ] crazy a lot of
shit's going on a lot of shit's popping
off damn Warren Buffett and Jay-Z gonna
stick out their dicks wow both those
guys so the picture was first published
on Tick Tock by one of the women who
appeared in the photo the the woman is a
former Miss Finland contestant and a
social media influencer okay and the
Finnish PM made headlines last week
after a video of her partying with her
pal serfs online the leak video had
prompted calls from fellow Finnish MPS
for the party loving prime minister to
undergo a voluntary drug test as the
people should be allowed to expect this
from their leader what was so bad about
that video for partying what was she
doing I think just the idea
on Snapchat you know so it was Janet
Reno no one gave a [ __ ] dude Trump hangs
out with Kodak Black you know what I
mean that's true to be fair she took a
drug test on Friday to clear up
suspicions which came back negative so
so it's time
but positive for chill-ass Vibes it
should be you could be they can ask for
drug here's politics you're a civil
servant yeah and and if you're in
California you can have wood in your
system be like hey it's legal here in
the days after the video found its way
to social media Finnish women have taken
to upload videos of themselves loves
dancing and posted them online in
support of their friends
fans are dope good people I want to move
there for fun and I'm gonna miss having
a gun so I'll come back how